qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la nature est
qu'à la vérité finit toujours par
éclater
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
des hospitalisations pour cause de kobe
continuent de progresser en france
environ 1000 personnes se trouvent dans
les services de réanimation
dans le même temps le gouvernement met
la pression sur la vaccination mais
l'extension du pasa littéraire est
contestée une manifestation contre le
projet
débutée tout à l'heure près de
l'assemblée nationale fait des élections
anticipées c'est ce que conseille et
narda la principale formation politique
au parlement tunisien le pays
s'engouffre dans une crise politique
après des manifestations sur tout le
territoire hilaire le président kenza
aide à limoger des ministres suspendu le
parlement et s'est octroyé le pouvoir
exécutif à l'ouverture d'une enquête
parlementaire qui divise washington des
policiers rappelé ce mardi la violence
de l'assaut sur le capital le 6 janvier
dernier
bennie thompson le chef démocrate de la
commission denquête a dénoncé un as ou
dix ans à faire dérailler la démocratie
la commission a le pouvoir de réclamer
des documents mais aussi de convoquer
des témoins les précisions dans ce
journal
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france convaincre les
français d'aller se faire vacciner
l'objectif du premier ministre
aujourd'hui en visite auprès d'habitants
de seine-saint-denis car la progression
du variant delta inquiète alors que la
france est entrée dans une quatrième
vague de la pandémie dans les hôpitaux
les patients atteints ducobu 19 sont bel
et bien là selon les données de santé
publique france ils sont presque 1000 en
réanimation
neuf cent soixante dix huit sont en
soins critiques ou les cas les plus
graves sont prises en charge une reprise
alors qu'un français sur deux a
désormais un schéma vaccinal complet à
l'exécutif qui compte aussi sur son
projet de loi d'extension du pass
sanitaires pour endiguer l'épidémie
[Musique]
ce projet de loi reste décriée par ceux
qui rejette la possibilité d'une
vaccination d'une obligation vaccinale
nouvelle mobilisation a débuté à 18
heures devant l'assemblée nationale le
cortège a pour destination le conseil
constitutionnel qui doit valider
l'extension de ce pass and i ter le 5
août le point avec notre reporter car
cette technique 50 gilet jaune et autres
anti passe sanitaires sont partis de
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui pour
rejoindre les abords du conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi et bien parce
que c'est la quête examiner le texte de
loi sanitaire en ce moment il compte
ainsi protester contre ces mesures
jugées liberticides et ne veulent pas
assez c'est la mobilisation je propose
de les écouter on est là pour leur
montrer qu on lâchera pas que la liberté
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui est
on doit arracher avec les dons c'est
quelque chose qui nous est d'une paye
est un pays libre nous sommes des
gaulois réfractaires n'en déplaise à
monsieur macron et les gaulois
réfractaires ils lui disent non non à sa
politique non à la tout ça là on n'est
pas beaucoup on n'était plus la semaine
dernière on était beaucoup plus le
week-end dernier on sera beaucoup plus
le week-end prochain
il n'y a pas de souci on ne lâchera pas
la faire pendant l'été ce clivage vaille
me désole plus que deux façons mais des
français en fait il fallait une fine et
c'est les français contre les français
et 100 kg est effectivement une
recherche une discussion qui permettent
aux uns et aux autres de saint-andré
sait écouter on est dans un discours
binaire et sur chaque question on est
pour ou les comptes ont fait des choses
sont beaucoup plus complexes il faut
effectivement pouvoir avoir des horizons
discussions et aux leurs yeux d'avoir
une information unique et matraqué à la
télé etc
c'est d'avoir des débats entre
scientifiques qui permettent d'avoir des
gens qui font une thèse antithèse
synthèse c'est ce qu'on a appris en
philosophie et c'est aussi la démarche
scientifique basée sur le doute et qui
permettent au sida semble d'intégrer des
citoyens dans la discussion
mais effectivement on retrouve à perdre
les valeurs républicaines qui sont de
liberté avec ses lois liberticides et
liberticide d'égalité serre que tout le
monde est égal devant leur égal devant
la loi et de fraternité qu'on a
effectivement complètement perdu ces
derniers jours de fortes mobilisations
ont eu lieu pour contester le pass
sanitaire alors que le texte du projet
de loi sanitaire poursuivre et son
parcours législatif
le texte a été approuvé après son
passage au sénat sont qu'il ne soit
beaucoup modifié mais l'opposition
parlementaire subsistent le texte est
désormais entre les mains du conseil
constitutionnel saisi par jean castex
mais aussi par 74 députés de gauche
ils ont émis un communiqué commun on
retrouve des parlementaires de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
la france insoumise des socialistes de
liberté territoire il note que certaines
dispositions en raison de leur caractère
disproportionné sont manifestement
contraire à plusieurs droits et libertés
que la constitution garantit
il pense bien sûr à la liberté d'aller
et venir pour les voyages et loisirs les
bars les restaurants mais aussi au
principe d'égalité car tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner ne
peuvent pas le faire faute de doses
les sages du conseil constitutionnel
rendront leur avis le 5 août pour se
rendre en espagne mieux vaut aussi avoir
son pass sanitaires il est exigé des
touristes français en provenance de
régions classées à risque elles sont
nombreuses les explications de clans
clémentine laurent l'espagne resserre la
vie se passe aux touristes français avec
la cinquième vague de kobe 19 et bien le
gouvernement espagnol continue à prendre
des mesures et la dernière en date c'est
que presque toutes les régions de france
sont classés en zone à risque et ce pour
au moins une semaine en fait pour faire
simple il n'ya que le centre val de
loire et la bourgogne franche comté qui
sont exemptés de ces mesures alors
concrètement les touristes en provenance
des régions à risque vont devoir
présenter à la frontière espagnole le
pass sanitaires et ceci est valable pour
tout le monde sauf pour les enfants de
moins de 12 ans et pour tous les
transports dont voies terrestres
aériennes et maritimes
en revanche pour ceux qui viendraient de
régions qui ne sont pas concernés et
bien aucun test ni aucun pack sanitaire
a présenté à la frontière il ne faut pas
oublier qu'en avion ou en bateau il faut
aussi se munir d'un formulaire qui est
disponible sur le site du ministère de
la santé espagnol
alors si le gouvernement ici en espagne
france et mesure c'est que les chiffres
de lakovic 19 sont toujours très
alarmant dans le pays et la catalogne
est la région la plus touchée à tel
point qu'elle doit des programmes et des
opérations non urgentes dans les
hôpitaux et elle maintient ces
restrictions
je vous propose d'écouter la part
gouvernement catalan pour la troisième
fois consécutive la catalogne prolonge
pour sept jours supplémentaires le
couvre-feu dans les villes les plus
touchées par la cinquième vague de
qu'ovide c'est une mesure difficile nous
le savons mais c'est une mesure efficace
qui est validée par les experts et les
scientifiques et pour les touristes
français qui souhaiterait tout de même
se rendre en espagne malgré la situation
sanitaire
il ne faut pas oublier que pour rentrer
en france il faudra présenter à la
frontière un test pcr ou antigénique
mais négatif datant de moins de 24
heures la vaccination obligatoire contre
le coc vide 19 en passe d'être actée
outre atlantique les états unis ont
enregistré plus de 88 mille cas ce lundi
en grande partie
duo variant delta face à la hausse des
contaminations de plus en plus de
responsables et d'élus se joignent aux
appels à la vaccination au moment où les
restrictions signent leur retour
hélène masculin les cas graves et les
décès sont de nouveau à la hausse depuis
plusieurs semaines aux états unis la
floride le texas et le missouri
représente 40% de tous les nouveaux cas
à l'échelle nationale qu'ils soient
politiques ou sanitaires et responsables
s'inquiètent de la hausse des infections
et blâment les non vaccinés
la californie état le plus peuplé du
pays a décidé de rendre le vaccin
obligatoire pour l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires dès le mois prochain
extase 46000 californiens sont employés
par l'état
446 me californien devrait être vaccinés
s'ils ne le sont pas ne sont pas en
mesure de prouver qu'ils ont été
vaccinées nous exigeons qu'il se passe
des tice et la californie c'est un gage
à contrôler la vaccination et md à
procéder à des dépistages hebdomadaire à
new york ce sont les mêmes mesures
une obligation qui s'appliquera à plus
de 300 milles personnes policiers
pompiers ou enseignant de la première
ville des états unis avec un calendrier
précis
le 13 septembre l'ensemble du personnel
de la ville devra en vertu du mandat de
sécurité face au co vide soit se faire
vacciner ce qui est de loin préférable
soit se soumettre à un test de dépistage
une fois par semaine
c'est en septembre que tout va se jouer
le variant delta s'est également
installé à springfield dans le missouri
avant de se répandre à travers tout
l'état qui remet en place des
restrictions la réalité de ce virus a
changé par rapport à il ya un an à la
demande des experts locaux en matière de
santé et du groupe de travail sur la
pandémie de saint louis
l'exécutif du comté le docteur sam page
et moi même avons pris des mesures et
instaurer un mandat sur le port du
masque pour stopper la propagation du
code isin
la maison blanche a annoncé que les
frontières américaines ne rouvrirait pas
aux voyageurs étrangers même s'ils sont
vaccinés au plan national
seulement 57 % de tous les américains
ont reçu au moins une dose et 49% sont
totalement vacciner et la campagne de
vaccination tourne au ralenti avec un
risque de fracture sociale la question
des vaccins est devenu le nouveau champ
de bataille politique outre atlantique
selon des sondages réalisés ces jours ci
la proportion de démocrates vacciner est
bien plus importantes que celles de
républicains
une crise sanitaire doublé désormais
d'une crise politique en tunisie le
président cas et cède à limoger hier les
ministres de la défense et de la justice
la veille il s'était séparé du premier
ministre après avoir suspendu les
travaux parlementaires pour un mois de
quoi provoquer des tensions ses soutiens
se sont opposés hier aux partisans
d'ennahdha principal parti au parlement
la situation est suivie de près à
l'étranger les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis bassem chez bis
depuis le coup de force du président de
la république tunisienne les réactions
se multiplient à l'international de
bruxelles à washington en passant par
paris tous suivent la situation de très
près et appelle à la stabilité politique
et institutionnelle du pays et coûté
nous sommes préoccupés par les
développements en tunisie qui
surviennent alors que les autorités
tunisiennes cherche à stabiliser leurs
économies à faire face à une résurgence
de la pandémie de copies de 19 et à
améliorer le niveau de vie de tous les
tunisiens
nous sommes en contact un haut niveau de
la maison blanche et du département
d'état avec les dirigeants tunisiens
pour en savoir plus sur la situation
appelé au calme et soutenir les efforts
tunisien pour avancer dans le respect
des principes démocratiques
la france souhaite le retour dans les
meilleurs délais à un fonctionnement
normal des institutions
elle appelle également l'ensemble des
forces politiques du pays à éviter toute
forme de violence et à préserver les
acquis démocratiques du pays ce qui se
passe en tunisie est un coup d'état
contre la constitution tunisienne et
contre la volonté populaire de nos
frères tunisiens
nous appelons le pouvoir algérien à
soutenir les institutions
légitimons tunisie de son côté le
président de la république est bien
déterminée à maintenir sa feuille de
route
un parlement gelé pour 30 jours des
députés privés de leur immunité et des
limogeages qui se succèdent après celui
du premier ministre
hichem et chichi qui a fini par
démissionner le président également chef
de l'armée a limogé le ministre de la
défense et la porte parole du
gouvernement également ministre de la
fonction publique ministre de la justice
par intérim du côté de la population
après les explosions de joie qui ont
suivi l'annoncé du président de la
république
nombreux sont les tunisiens qui
souhaitent voir un changement radical
s'opérer prochainement écouter une
décision sache
j'espère que c'est une décision sage
nous allons voir ce que vont donner les
jours qui suivent j'espère le meilleur
pour l'avenir car sincèrement la vie que
nous menons est très compliqué mais tout
le monde se sont étouffés
certains meurent de faim il n'y a que
des problèmes de produits sans parler du
chômage personne n'avance dans ce pays
j'espère que le meilleur reste à venir
nous sommes encore dans le foot mais
tant que le peuple et aux côtés du
président de la république ce qui nous
attend ne peut être que positif
i'm not hollywood j'achète aussi les
forces de l'ordre et l'armée syrienne
appartiennent au peuple tunisien et à la
tunisie et à la sécurité
j'espère vraiment qu'il va y avoir une
stratégie de travail
la situation va changer arrivé en tant
que tunisiens à l'étranger
il est surpris par l'état dans lequel
j'ai retrouvé mon pays
sans parler du cofidab j'espère vraiment
que la situation va évoluer avec la
stratégie de la part du président de la
république c'est la meilleure décision
prise 11 ans même si cette décision
aurait dû être prise il ya quatre ou
cinq années déjà il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution intermédiaire ce qui
nous attend ne peut être que meilleure
vous pensez vraiment qu'on peut vivre
pire que ce que nous avons déjà vécu
c'est impossible
le parti ennahda qui accuse le président
d'un coup d'état constitutionnel a
indiqué dans un communiqué son souhait
d'organiser des élections législatives
et présidentielle anticipées après le
coup de force du président sayed afin de
garantir la protection du processus
démocratique et d'éviter que tout retard
ne serve de prétexte au maintien d'un
régime autocratique
en attendant elle est tunisien suspendu
aux décisions du président de la
république demeure dans un pays qui
oscille entre crises politiques
économiques et sanitaires et après avoir
dénoncé un coup d'état et nada se dit
prêt à la tenue d'élections législatives
et présidentielle anticipée le président
qu'est l'état est d'entendre at-il cet
appel
écoutez ce qu'en pensent les céistes a
means no 6
je pense que la dissolution du parlement
pour lui ne est un outil pour modifier
la constitution
même s'il n'a pas le droit de le faire
et qu'il n'y a pas de conventionnel
on a vu que le ce n'est pas la légalité
qui l'empêché de concrétiser son projet
politique mais je pense que c'est la
solution la tenue d'élections anticipées
législatives et présidentielle parce que
là cette prise de position est pour moi
ne peut le positionner que comme
président temporaire on ne peut pas
garder comme président de la république
quelqu'un qui ne respecte pas la
constitution sauf s'il se représente et
qu'il regagne évidemment mais la tenue
d'élections anticipées législatives et
présidentielles pour moi est la seule
issue possible
dans l'actualité également ce
rapprochement inattendu entre les deux
corées un an après leur suspension séoul
et pyongyang restaure leurs canaux de
communication une annonce positive en
vue d'un réchauffement des relations
entre les deux pays et qui coïncide avec
l'anniversaire de l'armistice entre les
deux corées françois disque est vite ch
c'est dans un bureau de liaison
semblable à celui ci qu'un officiels
sud-coréens a échangé avec son homologue
en corée du nord
un premier appel téléphonique via les
canaux de communication officielle
depuis plus d'un an un réchauffement des
relations débuté en avril dernier par
des lettres échangées entre le président
sud coréen moudjahidine et le leader
nord-coréen kim jong hoon
les deux leaders ont avancé sur cette
reprise des relations intercoréennes
depuis avril dernier via de nombreux
échanges de lettres au cours de ces
discussions ils se sont mis d'accord
pour ouvrir les lignes de communication
un peu la soirée pour les deux
dirigeants ont également convenu de
rétablir la confiance mutuelle entre les
deux corées
dès que possible et améliorer les
relations intercoréennes en juin 2020 la
corée du nord avait décidé
unilatéralement de couper tous ces
canaux officiels de communication
militaire et politique dénonçant l'
envoi sur son territoire de tracts de
propagande anti pyongyang une suspension
au moment où les discussions inter
coréennes étaient au point mort deux ans
après les trois sommets qui avait réuni
le leader nord-coréen kim jong hoon et
le président sud-coréen moudjahid des
rencontres qui avait débouché sur le
premier sommet de l'histoire entre à
leader nord-coréen est un président
américain en exercice
mais le fiasco de la rencontre kim trump
à hanoï la capitale du vietnam en
février 2019 avait mis à l'arrêt le
processus intercoréen et les
négociations sur les programmes
nucléaires et balistiques de pyongyang
finalement ce mardi contre toute attente
les deux pays annonce le rétablissement
de toutes les communications les plus
hauts dirigeants du nord et du sud sont
tombés d'accord pour faire un grand pas
vers le rétablissement de la confiance
mutuelle et la promotion de la
réconciliation en restaurant les lignes
de communication inter coréens
qui ont été suspendus une annonce
d'autant symbolique qu'elle coïncide
avec le 68ème anniversaire de la fin de
la guerre de corée selon certains
experts
ce réchauffement actuel des relations
seraient un moyen pour pyongyang en
pleine crise de kovy 19 d'obtenir un
allégement des sanctions internationales
mais aussi et surtout un signal
d'ouverture envoyé au gouvernement
américain de joe biden et pour jean
vincent brisset directeur de recherche à
l'institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques
ce rapprochement entre les deux corées
étaient prévisibles
on écoute l'armistice n'ont pas vraiment
la fin la fin des opérations n'est pas
la fin de la guerre les pays sont encore
techniquement en guerre il n'y a pas eu
d'accord de paix signés en dehors de ça
je pense que il y avait déjà des
frémissements 1 puisque même la corée du
sud avait présenté une candidature pour
les jeux olympiques de 2022
il a échoué c'est brisbane péter choisi
mais déjà il y avait quelque chose qui
se passait et là je pense qu'il ya un
nouveau peut-être qu'au cours des jeux
olympiques même si la croiser une on y
participe à un frémissement de relations
dans la région parce qu'il ya nombreux
déplacements de personnel politique pas
forcément de très haut niveau et
personnel politique relativement
important des américains à pékin des
gens qui se rencontrent en marge des
jeux olympiques 1 et qui peuvent
discuter sur un plan technique
retour sur l'assaut du capital le 6
janvier dernier par les partisans de
donald trump une commission d' enquête
parlementaire a été ouverte par l'élue
démocrate bennie thompson de vifs débats
ont eu lieu appuyés par des témoignages
de policiers présents sur place
pour plus de détails on retrouve notre
correspondant à washington thomas
bowness
bonsoir thomas que retenir de cette
première journée bien cette audition a
duré environ trois heures et demie elle
s'est ouvert sur une vidéo compilant des
scènes de violence qui se sont déroulés
le 6 janvier dernier lors de cette
attaque contre le capitole et puis il ya
donc eu ces auditions quatre policiers
qui étaient présents au moment des faits
on a pu voir beaucoup d'émotion leur
part que ce soit des larmes ou parfois
même de la colère et puis ce qui
ressortit surtout c'est la peur qu'ils
ont ressentie face à cette foule de
manifestants et coûté par exemple ce
témoignage d'un officier de police qui
était présent sur place pour être
honnête je n'ai pas reconnu mes
concitoyens qui ont pris d'assaut le
capitole le 6 janvier dernier les états
unis qu'ils prétendaient représenter
j'avais 25 ans et sergent dans l'armée
j'avais été déployés en irak pour
l'opération liberté irakienne de temps à
temps je me suis porté volontaire pour
voyager sur des routes infestées
d'engins explosifs improvisés les mener
des missions de ravitaillement pour les
forces américaines et alliées ainsi que
pour la population irakienne 2021 pour
la première fois j'ai eu plus peur en
travaillant au capitole que pour dans
l'ensemble de mon déploiement en irak
avec l'armée américaine en irak
nous nous attendions à la violence armée
car nous étions en zone de guerre mais
aucune expérience dans l'armée ou en
tant qu'officier des forces de l'ordre
ne m'a préparé pour ce que nous avoir
affronté le 6 janvier alors il faut
noter qu'un certain nombre des policiers
qui ont témoigné ce mardi ont été
blessés lors de cette attaque contre le
capitole l'un d'entre eux à d'ailleurs
déclaré j'aurais pu mourir à plusieurs
reprises ce jour là on a aussi pu voir
d'ailleurs une vidéo qui était issue
d'une caméra embarquée sur l'un des
officiers de police qui a témoigné lors
de cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire
on voit les scènes de violence contre
lui à ce moment là où ils crient même à
plusieurs reprises j'ai des enfants
comme pour tenter de convaincre la foule
manifestant de l'est
barnier d'ailleurs les manifestants sont
régulièrement qualifiés de terroristes
dans les différents témoignages qu'on a
pu entendre ce mardi dans cette
commission
l'un des policiers fait également
référence à cette attaque contre le
capitole comme d'une bataille
moyenâgeuse et puis un autre policier
indique lui avoir reçu beaucoup
d'insultés racistes lors donc de cette
attaque
il ya eu donc plusieurs questions de la
part des parlementaires pour tenter de
revenir sur le déroulé précis des faits
sur l'attitude et les propos qui ont été
tenus par les manifestants présents ce
jour là et puis il y à une question
principale surtout qui a été abordé quel
est le rôle du président donald trump
dans cette attaque il ya par exemple un
policier qui affirme que des
manifestants ont déclaré ces donald
trump qui nous a envoyé est évidemment
toute la lumière va devoir être faite
sur le rôle précis du président
américain dans cette attaque contre le
capitole il faut noter que la création
même de cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire a provoqué beaucoup de
débats ici aux etats unis puisque
initialement
les élus démocrates voulait constituer
une commission sur le même modèle que
celle qui avait précédé qui avait suivi
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 ça a
été refusé par les républicains et puis
donc lorsqu'est venu le moment de
choisir qui est l'élu aller siéger dans
cette commission les républicains ont
proposé des noms et deux d'entre eux ont
été refusées par nancy pelosi qui est la
chef de file des démocrates à la chambre
des représentants conséquence le chef de
file des républicains kevin mccarthy a
décidé de retirer toutes les nominations
et résultats finalement il n'y a que
deux républicains au sein de cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire de
républicains qui sont déjà assez éloigné
de la ligne officielle du parti
puisqu'il avait voté à l'époque en
faveur de la procédure d' impeachment
contre donald trump alors ces deux élus
républicains c'est d'abord liste gêné
qui a déclaré qu'elle voulait décortiqué
minute par minute ce qu'il s'était passé
à la maison blanche lors de l' attaque
contre le capitole et puis l'autre
républicain c'est adam kissinger qui
justement est revenu sur les polémiques
qui ont entouré la création de cette
commission et vous allez voir il a aussi
ressenti beaucoup d'émotion au moment de
prendre la parole je ne m'attendais pas
à ce que ce jour soit aussi émouvant
pour moi j'ai parlé un certain nombre
d'entre vous et j'ai appris à vous
connaître
je pense qu'il est important de vous le
dire maintenant vous devez peut-être une
sentir un peu brisé
vous parlez tous des effets auxquels
vous devez faire face et de l'impact
qu'a eu ce jour sur vous mais vous avez
gagné vous avez tenu vous savez des
démocraties ne sont pas définies par nos
mauvais jour mais de comment nous
revenons de ses mauvais jours des
responsabilités que nous prenons comme
la plupart des américains je suis
frustré que six mois après qu'une
insurrection meurtrière est percé le
capitole des états unis pendant
plusieurs heures en direct à la
télévision
nous ne savons toujours pas ce qu'il
s'est passé pourquoi parce que beaucoup
de membres de mon parti on traiter cela
comme une simple lutte partisane alors
le lancement de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire n'a pas mis fin
aux polémiques puisque kevin mccarthy
donc le leader des républicains
qualifient cette commission d'imposture
et puis de son côté donald trump
reproche à cette même commission
son manque d'impartialité il faut noter
qu'il n'y a pas de date de fin encore
pour les travaux de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire et qu'une audition
pourrait de nouveau être organisées
d'ici la fin du mois d'août et travaux
que l'on continuera à suivre
grâce à vous merci thomas boni notre
correspondant à washington
à morts quatre disparus 31 blessés dont
cinq graves c'est le dernier bilan de
l'explosion ce matin sur un site de
gestion de déchets à leverkusen dans
l'ouest de l'allemagne
après l'apparition d'un immense nuage de
fumée provoqué par l'incendié il a été
demandé aux résidents de la zone de
s'enfermer dans des lieux cloisonnée en
attendant l'intervention des pompiers
l'usiné temps classée comme site
chimique les autorités craignent que des
substances dangereuses se soient
propagées dans l'air écouté le directeur
du site que j'exprime nos condoléances
aux proches des victimes
nous avons une responsabilité nous
faisons face et en même temps nous avons
encore quatre personnes disparues et
nous faisons tout pour les retrouver
ou bien collaboration avec les pompiers
professionnels c'est un événement grave
pour leverkusen leurs dernières poignées
de mains remonte à plus de dix ans le
président ivoirien alassane ouattara et
son prédécesseur laurent gbagbo se
retrouve ce soir à abidjan les deux
hommes ont déjà eu un contact
téléphonique au début du mois de juillet
une rencontre pour sceller la
réconciliation nationale retour en
images sur ce qui s'apparente un
réchauffement des relations entre ces
deux vielles vous
et deux
une
[Musique]
oui
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on
alors que certains s'attendaient à un
baby boom
il semblerait que la france se dirige
tout droit vers ce que l'on appelle un
baby crash
les gens ont peur les gens ont moins
d'argent donc évidemment il
ils font moins dans